command the seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest
free-to-play combat game world of
warships download now hi guys I'm Lucy
and welcome to in two minutes the
wargaming.net came to us offering to
sponsor a video about their new game
world of warships now I'm not exactly
what you would call an expert on
warships but I do know a thing about the
company wargaming themselves and they've
got a pretty interesting history they
turned what was always seen as kind of a
niche hobby into one of the biggest
free-to-play MMO in the world and it's
weird to think that it all started with
watermelon seed as a child wargaming's
founder Victor his Lee made a tabletop
game by drawing basic geography on the
floor and used household items like
seeds for units playing against his
brother he not only found himself in
love with wargaming but also its
community so much so that he'd later
name a whole company after it university
enabled kids Lee to go on an exchange
visit to the US which inspired him he
wanted the American Dream of riches and
success so how did he go about achieving
that well he ran it up some friends to
help him program a game iron age a cross
between RISC Panzer General and Civ Iron
Age sadly well about four people played
it but one of those people who went by
the name Tiger would prove key to
wargaming's future undeterred cos lee
and KO went on to make their first
profitable game a digital version of the
tabletop ruleset DeBellis antiquity
artists or DBA funded by a monthly
subscription service that gave players
access to more content and powered by
hordes of ramen fuels undergrad
programmers DBA launched in 2000 owning
a strong following and crucially a lot
of money with a team of 12 and some
spare dollar the new wargaming turned
their hand at something a little more
mass-market and what's more mass-market
than robots massive assault was a
robot's mashie tactic him up that would
prove to be both critically and
commercially successful spurning a
couple of sequels and generally becoming
the backbone for wargaming for a good
few years but times change and sadly the
PC market starts to wane due to growing
piracy levels so wargaming took on some
work on the side which would prove to be
a lifeline they made some advertising
tech for a small us-based startup a
small us-based startup that ended up
getting sold to Yahoo for 300 million
dollars wargaming took their 10 million
dollar share and used that to fund
development for a new game now the idea
for a free-to-play title was already
fair but what to make well remember
Tiger he introduced his Li to an old
Russian tactical warship titled Navy
Field which inspired wargaming to create
a tank based MMO which would eventually
become World of Tanks from there the
company expanded both in size and in
scope from four players to over a
hundred million registered accounts from
one dorm room to 15 offices worldwide
from watermelon scenes on the kitchen
floor to their brand-new game world of
warships so I thought it was kind of
cool that a studio could start at the
bottom where the bottom is an actual
kitchen floor and now we're here which
is you know all the successful stuff I
talked about earlier that's the show for
this week guys thanks for watching don't
forget you can find me on Twitter at
Lucy James game and I'll see you next
time